hi i'm steve carell and i'm going to be
breaking down some iconic scenes from
despicable me and minions
[Applause]
will you read as a bedtime story
no
that scene where gru is reading the
bedtime story he's sort of cajoled
um to me is the scene where
that character becomes a father and not
to overthink it but it's a huge turning
point for that character because
these kids touch this part of him that
he's never felt before and he's
struggling with it because it's not who
he believes himself to be and you see
the like the warmth coming inside of him
but what's funny is that he's trying to
push it away he's trying to
you know retain that persona that he's
always had and he's he's struggling with
it and it's there's a sweetness to it
and kids don't care and which is sweet
too kids need certain things
they yearn for that that warmth and
parental
guidance i guess and love and he
grudgingly starts to give into it a
little bit it's a sweet scene
so while you sleep we are apart
your mommy
loves you with all her heart
the end okay good night
it's funny to see gru when he's trying
to be gruff but he can't anymore like
his
his kinder gentler self
just
you know comes through starts to
permeate um starts to kind of break down
this facade that he creates for himself
when we
record these
i think part of the the trick is to give
as many different options as you can
because you never know
how it's going to edit together and
what's going to feel right based on
the other performances because we don't
you know do any performance with any
other actors so you kind of have to
preemptively
give as many options as you can to um
then try to help help it all fit
together
wait
what
what about goodnight kisses
no no no there will be no kissing or
hugging or kissing
[Music]
he's not gonna kiss us good night agnes
i like him he's nice but scary
like santa
the animators and the writers of these
films have done
such a beautiful job in creating these
characters and
they're alive before they're even
performed you can feel it you know you
can feel this relationship
that
in the first one
that's developing between these children
and this this guy
what's beautiful to me about it is these
are these are people who just need each
other and the journey of them you know
coming together
kind of despite
their upbringings and backgrounds it's
it's very sweet but i really
i have to give all the credit to
the creators of this and i'm you know
i'm supplying this voice and i'm trying
to
to bring it to life in a certain way but
it's it's really all there to begin with
[Music]
up to this point our relationship has
been strictly professional
and you're leaving for australia and all
but
okay here is the question
would you like to
[Music]
to go out on a date
uh no
okay that's not helping
when i was a kid asking a girl out for
the first time
i i understand that whole
impulse to want to
practice it i didn't practice it with a
friend gru practices it with a minion
it's such a nerve-wracking experience
and it's different in this day and age
too
um i you know i see my
kids and and they communicate with their
friends
with texts but that actual
being
right you know right at the front of it
with your voice on a phone and facing
facing the rejection first hand
and the first girl i ever asked out on a
date
flat out said no she didn't even give an
excuse
she just said no i don't want to do that
so it didn't work out as well for me but
it's it's
it's gratifying to see
characters that you play succeed in that
way and maybe that's why i became an
actor because i can i can live out a
life that i didn't have in reality
[Music]
i would never advise anyone to take
advice from a minion
um or to take anything a minion does
seriously they are wonderful
and they're they're loyal and kind and
fun
but do not do not follow a minion's
advice you that will lead you down the
wrong path
[Music]
here we are
oh how's it going
it's me crew and me draw
i hug everybody whether they like it or
not
why are they pretending to be each other
we played around with the different
versions of the drew voice and it
obviously had to be
it had to have the same base as gru
but it had to have reflected a
completely different upbringing in a
different part of the world it was a fun
scene to do because
to watch
someone with a very thick
vaguely eastern european accent try to
do
a different accent
of you know his
his twin brother which is kind of just
fun as an as a
as a little voice acting piece and and
vice versa
to have them sort of do their
impressions of the other
was uh i think a fun bit of writing ah
what's for dinner i probably won't like
it i'm so grumpy all the time
i laugh a lot and i'm kind of needy
[Laughter]
the whole idea for that i think is such
a strong
comedic idea you know people
with with such outlandish
personas and accents trying to
replicate somebody else's and be bad at
it it was just a really funny conceit to
me
oh look he's made grow
and i'm drew we switched please
oh it's so nice to see you two are
getting along oh we're getting along
perfectly
wait did we just finish each other's
sentences
oh that's delightful not creepy at all
and you're gonna stop now though right
sorry it's a twin thing all of these
movies are really about relationships
and about
connections different types of
connections that people have with each
other and i think it's one of the
reasons that they resonate because it's
all even though it's animated it's all
very human if the first one has to do
with him becoming a father for the first
time and the second one had to do with
him falling in love
and having a relationship like a
romantic relationship this one
was like another component that hadn't
existed in his life
which was
that sibling relationship which is you
know not everyone gets to experience but
it's um to not have had that and then to
suddenly
be able to experience it is
for gru was sort of
exciting but daunting at the same time
because
you know for something like that i think
you imagine what life would be like like
what would what would my sibling be like
what
who would that person even what would
our relationship be
and then when he meets this person and
it's not exactly
how he thought it would be or or how he
might have envisioned it it gets a
little complicated but you know but
funny at the same time
[Music]
no
i don't think so
most kids have you know big
big ideas you go through the oh i want
to be a professional hockey player i
want to
you know i want to be a fireman i want
like you have these different sort of
goals in in life and they're very pure
and his his pure vision of himself
is
evil is to be a
an evil mastermind and the
the most
fierce villain in the world but at the
same time
he's like 11
and or like 10 or 11 at that point so
he's still a kid you know he's still
extremely vulnerable and he's just he's
he's just
shaping himself or being shaped what i
like about it is that you know you see
you see the
the seeds of who he becomes later but
he's still a kid there's a child like
joy
to
the the way he is you know pursuing his
life you have no idea who you are
messing with i am the greatest
supervillain of all time
oh where are you
everything with young guru in terms of
the voice just tightens up a little bit
so that laugh becomes as he gets older
becomes obviously a fuller and lower
laugh
but uh
he's a little squeaky as young crew
it's a quick scene but it's they
they see this
villain in the making
and are taken by it it's it's i think
it's a really funny moment because
they're in awe
they see their future in him and they
fall in love with his villainy
and his you know
his evilness
and and i think the potential that he
has in that world
[Music]
gru is applying to become a member of
the vicious sex and
they don't realize that
you know when they invite him to come in
that he's just a little kid and they're
kind of dressing him down and you know
kind of brushing him off like you know
come back when you're an adult this is
ridiculous why are you even here and to
prove to them that he's less up to the
task
he steals this gemstone from them and
he's very
very adept and he's good at it and he
makes you know makes his way out with it
what i love about that scene is is
how intimidated he is
but how he's overcoming
all of this fear
and
all of this anxiety i mean it's you know
he's really
out of his league certainly in terms of
his his age so it's all very daunting
but he acquits himself quite well
[Music]
the gadgets are are incredibly important
he's got a jet bike you know these are
part and parcel with with what makes him
such a great villain
[Music]
i think the character of gru has
resonated with people he's gone through
a lot of different
uh phases and
he's grown
as a person
and i think people enjoy that to see
someone develop and grow
and
mature
and uh
and find joy in life within
this you know despicable world that he
lives in
the building
[Applause]
wow
[Music]